hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy and i just wanted to give a huge
shout out and thank you to elon musk and
everyone at the musk foundation for
their incredibly generous support for
khan academy they just recently gave a 5
million dollar donation to khan academy
elon i hope you really feel good about
this this is going to allow us to
accelerate all sorts of content
our aspirations are all subjects from k
through the early stages of college this
will accelerate our science content
allow us to do more on early learning
allow us to make the software and the
practice that much more engaging for
millions of students around the world
for teachers around the world and as far
as khan academy has come we have 120
million registered users 20 or 30
million students using the platform
every month uh we have about 200 million
hours of learning a year which any way
you want to evaluate that that's that's
worth a lot to the world when you look
at our efficacy studies and how we've
been able to move the dial in classrooms
our just that social return to
investment ratio is 400 to 500 to 1.
a good return in the philanthropic
sector is considered a five to one ratio
or ten to one ratio so as much as
progress has made been made
i think you appreciate and hopefully
everyone watching appreciates that
there's many billions who need this
there's people throughout the planet who
need a way to tap into their potential
and i view this type of investment in
what we're doing as really foundational
for us to be able to build a
multi-generational institution so that
future elon musks of the world are also
able to tap into their potential and
help all of us up level who we are
as a civilization
for everyone listening i want to remind
folks that as incredible as this
donation is and it really is incredible
that we do need more help we continue to
be running at a deficit for
2021 so every donation of every size
helps and we're able to take every one
of those dollars and it helps us
accelerate learning in a whole bunch of
dimensions the world as a whole spends
five trillion dollars on education
annually khan academy's budget is one
one hundred thousandth of that we are
the budget of a large high school but
our aspirations are to serve the globe
so hopefully uh we we
more folks listening at all scales uh
can help support what we're trying to do
and the last thing i'll mention and you
know it's especially powerful to get a
donation from you elon i had the
privilege of interviewing you back in
2013 when you visited our office and
someone on youtube commented i want to
find someone who looks at me the same
way that sal looks at elon and they were
catching on to something
i do look up to you an incredible way
any time that i i question even myself
and i say is this mission too big to
actually try to educate all of humanity
i think of the incredible work that
you've done i remember back in 2013 when
we were when i interviewed you pretty
much everything you said you were going
to do and these and you made some pretty
large statements you have either done or
you are very close to doing right now
and i take incredible inspiration that
it is not too big of a mission that if
anything we cannot shy away right now
from this goal just as we shouldn't shy
away from solving climate solving
transportation being able to colonize
other planets
we can't shy away from educating the
planet and other planets going forward
so thank you so much and and i look
forward to going on this journey with
all of y'all